[Music]
okay scene 3 tonight yes like just like
a marathon first thing we saw was uh
Godzilla king of the monsters if you if
you saw the first Godzilla you probably
like this one because I think it's
probably better than that yeah I mean I
like that one
although I private the city king of King
Kong felon let's go Island yeah one
can't call this better yeah it's just I
guess it's almost kind of like true the
original Godzilla movies I think you
know the main attraction is all these
monsters it's really definitely it's
really hard to compete with these
monsters and the rest of the characters
in the story to me were just kind of
like somehow in the way of seeing the
lobsters yeah sure whether much to this
you know and then every time they would
every time they show the monsters some
bad [ __ ] be going on then they go back
to the characters I don't really give a
[ __ ] what they're doing I want to go
back to see what the monsters just
monsters yeah and then the monsters were
pretty impressive you know I was really
into the monster zero you know King
Ghidorah you know Dedra however you want
to pronounce it looks badass
Mothra Rodin and but it kind of gets to
the point to where they start doing the
same kind of jump scares with the
monsters as soon as it gets quiet you
know it's gone by I almost fell asleep
in what time
today 2014 ya the first part of this
like alright yeah I like this one better
but I would say that this it visually it
was good but if the story was not super
yeah yeah yeah like I felt like the
characters were not like I loved the
girl that Ken Watanabe those doing good
you know humans like those are the like
kind of the main characters that I liked
in the rest of the characters that are
really good yeah the way they showed the
US Army was all [ __ ] up there yeah
then they cut away and then they cut
away yeah I feel like the it was really
quick too like a lot of minutes I felt
like like it look if it was like kind of
cool this it was like dark and like but
a lot of times I couldn't tell what's
going on yeah because it was kind of
dark and they edited so quickly that I
could tell yeah so it's like to me it
was just it was fine it's just it was
just kind of the way the US Army was
portrayed was just totally [ __ ] up
every time they show they're in slightly
different uniforms and they're wearing
more than one uniform at the same time I
saw one guy with a damp patch on
upside-down and they had a general the
flags are on backwards on his uniform it
just [ __ ] up you know Devan it's just
that you know that they just had them
stuck on the wrong you know cuz they're
velcro so you just put them on the wrong
side so and then you look at the person
now they get a little bit too [ __ ]
locusts you know I mean we're like
everybody in the army is
it is female and everyone is non-white
and stuff you know but the terrorists
they're all white just it's just knock
it off they just try to play too many
games you know and it's it didn't look
like the army to me you know I'm still
in contact with guys that are in you are
bad and now the army looks you know and
after serving in it and everything and
that just irks me when the uniforms are
wrong and it's just the way things work
it's I know there's no monsters you know
names but still there is an army make it
look like the army you know it kind of
takes me out of it I like small island a
lot better just because the characters
were a lot more compelling it's not like
the monster fights are cool and it's
like yeah I couldn't like I kind of hard
times like I said following it the Edit
was like really quick I couldn't tell
he's going on most of the time it was
just a decent watch right anyway it's
forgettable yeah
Skull Island was a lot better because
you had
and samuel l.jackson you not I mean he's
kind of like a driving force behind that
movie you know and he he made it so the
human characters were interesting and
studded sky like the other and this one
was there just kind of forgettable and I
think that's probably the problem with
this Godzilla movie is it ultimately
it's just going to be forgettable that's
kind of a problem
[Music]
but it's like yeah but it's gonna be
forgettable yeah we saw the first God's
new Godzilla forgot that we saw I saw it
again ran it twice well that's not
forgettable the person was and then
they're like oh I guess we should see
the first Godzilla like since we're
gonna see Godzilla king of the monsters
were all ready to get we stopped it yeah
I'm getting like this is all for me yeah
you
okay second one myself was uh was a
horror movie called Bob would you call
them horror movie one excited drama yeah
about this crazy-ass black chick starts
hanging out these high school students
and giving them a place to part in their
house and then I can't spoil it I just
can't split it one thing leads to
another and it just gets weirder and
[ __ ] weirder as it goes and it's what
school is its bunch of high school kids
and it's a bunch of adults wouldn't you
see in the movie in the theater was a
bunch of high school kids and they were
in their [ __ ] clapping and screaming
and whoa you know I'm just off there
laughing yeah it was in my opinion it
was an excellent [ __ ] summer horse
I love yeah real good is that things he
just they're on spring go they draw on
summer break right now right yeah this
is like a summer break movie for high
schoolers yeah but adults too it's
[ __ ] creep photo we remember fine
yeah I didn't I didn't see a lot of it
comment okay you know it was an original
very original script
this woman that plays really Batman yeah
knocked it out the park she was almost
like sympathetic but then like they need
though that no then you find out not
really though and then yeah it's just
like this creepy coming pitch around at
it like in the trailer and you know they
they're cheap and that's mansions it's
basically yeah it's like a register but
I I really liked yeah it just got like
particular that I'm thinking of that
everybody was just yeah and it's pretty
accurate high school suburban country
type but she you know they're going to
rock piles and making lot of fires yeah
yeah yeah
San Diego I don't know I think was just
some generic place didn't like didn't
look like California license plates
that's what I would say I thought it
looked like this house
yeah something it doesn't really matter
generic like Colorado
yeah and as I get on yeah looked like
just some backwater yeah yeah I
thoroughly enjoyed it I liked it better
than God's up well like I said this was
actually yeah like this was terrible
horror movie that's like horrific [ __ ]
happens and like imagine a fright night
was more realistic and it was scary
yeah and I remember how that kinda night
and lost boys you know but it's my mom
yeah this sounds like a comedic I
wouldn't call it a horror comedy exactly
but it didn't have like a comedic edge
to it
yeah well teenagers do some dumb [ __ ]
they're doing dumb [ __ ] yeah so like I
said it would cause your horror
psychodrama kind of so long as a psycho
mom as long you know in that same UNESCO
thank God it is in that same genres like
psycho
yeah like digital yeah after they
recommend I mean I really like and this
movie it's really short it's only like
an hour 30 minutes long
yeah I was just like yeah good movie I
was just like I love see ya and they've
been playing they're playing mind games
with you did the movie make trying to
make your skin crawl
yeah I liked it recommend it yeah I
definitely did and like I said go see at
the theater especially playing a big
crowd yeah see there's a bunch of kids
[Laughter]
you
okay boy it's been a long night today
was soft three I've been a rope I just
got done seeing the rocket man if you're
expecting something like Bohemian
Rhapsody it's not a movie like that it's
a it's a good movie it's a it's a
musical along the lines I'd say like
[Music]
that first couple like maybe 10-15
minutes of the movie I was having a hard
time getting my bearings about what kind
of movie it was I wasn't really sure if
I liked it but then prob about 15
minutes into it I'm fun okay I see where
they're going with it
they've gotten better I think as he got
into his adult years it starts off with
him as a kid
although it is important to the story as
it as the story unfolds early but yeah I
liked it yeah pretty good take on
InTouch performances we're also yeah and
the story's good
Bellamy Dorothy I mean a lot is
compressed into
to our movie but you know they pretty
much just it kind of highlights kind of
focuses a little bit on his you know
downward spiral yes what drugs yeah it
starts out with him going into rehab but
yeah and he's kind of like telling his
story
past but in that but even with that
focus it's like it's still like a really
fun movie it's like a visually really
cool moving like a lot of that a lot of
the set pieces like a lot of dancers and
stuff like that are really really cool
yeah obviously like sound like it yeah
the music was good but yeah they did
really good mixes of the music and you
know they it was kind of cool the way
they you know just kind of fitted into
the story yeah each song fit into
something and so that's why they kind of
like hit the highlights of like the life
oh yeah you know what that song might
have been talking about I think this
movie will be successful I don't think
it'll be as successful but he never
absolutely but maybe yeah it's a little
bit I mean it's a different condom yeah
it's yeah it's still a music biopic sort
of but it's not really this
kind of thing even though it does kind
of like it was a little bit into you
know how we got successful you know it's
a big thing but it's it's a musical it's
definitely more of a straight-up music
[Music]
traditional music yeah I would recommend
the movie though I knew I really liked
it I liked it
I'm good
[Music]